بعد غياب سبعه اشهر عن الانعقاد نجاح رئيس
حكومه تصريف الاعمال نجيب ميقاتي بلم شملي
وزراه ورغم بيان التيار الوطني الحربي
مقاطعه تسعه من الوزراء الجلسه جاءت
الضربه ناقصه مع تراجع وزير الصناعه
المحسوب على التشناق عن قرار المقاطعه
يكتمل النصاب بحضوره
اكد خبراء قانونيون على دستورتها
انا
شخصيا ورغم اتهام التيار الوطني الحر رئيس
الوزراء بالتعدي على صلاحيات رئيس
الجمهوريه الا انه رضا خالي واقع انعقادها
بعد فشله بتامين الثلث المعطل
ان نتشاور كحكومه
لكيفيه ضمن المسؤوليه الوطنيه العليا
في هذا الفراغ ان نتشاور لكيفيه اداره
البلاد في هذه المرحله لغايه
انتخاب رئيس جمهوريه
الى جوله من معركه رئاسيه وقف فيها حزب
الله هذه المره بالمرصاد لحليفه جبرا
باسيل
فوازير التشناق ما كان ليتراجع عن
المقاطعه دون ضغط الحزب خاصه وان باسيل
لمح اكثر من مره بخروجه من جلباب حسن نصر
الله الرئاسي يحكى ان هناك حوالي 800 مريض
سرطان بحاجه الى ادويه بشكل عاجل ومن ضمن
هؤلاء نصفهم من بيئه حزب الله وبالتالي هو
لا يستطيع ان ان لا يؤمن نصاب هذه الجلسه
كما انه يزكزك التيار الوطني اكثر من ملف
وطريقه
لدفعه للسير بمشرحه استعمال الفلاجي وقد
يكون ما حصل اليوم في يندرج ايضا في هذا
الاطار ولكن كما عالمنا التيار الوطني
الحر همم لا يتقبل ما يحصل يعتبر ان الدور
المسيحي تماما كما سلاح حزب الله ان انتم
تعتبرون سلاحكم اولويه بالنسبه لكم نحن
نعتبر دورا وهمم في هذه الدوله هو
الاولويه بالنسبه لنا
لا يخفى ان الجلسه اثارت حفيظه الشارع
المسيحي وان كان لاسباب مغيره عن حسابات
التيار لكنه ميقاتي لم يخفي امكانيه تكرار
التجربه مع استمرار الفراغ الرئاسي جلسه
ببنود طريقه لم تلغي الجدل السياسي الذي
عاده ما يرافق الاستحقاقات في لبنان وسط
ازمه مستمره منذ اربعه اعوام اغنيه يتيم
العربيه بيروت